hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one general idea that runs throughout
Aristotle's ethics then he brings up at
numerous points of ethnic McKean ethics
and really throughout his entire corpus
whenever he's dealing with human beings
is that of self-control and this is
something like I put here that is a good
quality it's on the side of goodness
rather than on the side of badness he
actually says that you know if you
divide human beings down the line you
know you're gonna find the
self-controlled and the virtuous and
then those of superhuman virtue on one
side those who are lacking self-control
those were vicious those who are brutal
or beasts chill on the other side and
then you know quite a few people like a
borderline between them it's not as good
as virtue because it's not as complete
virtue remember is what Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics is really aiming
after taking as its criteria but he also
thinks that there's a lot of people in
the world who are good in the sense that
their self-control even if they don't
already have virtue those people might
be in fact the way
if they continue to exercise
self-control but they're not yet there
and we'll take a look at why that is in
just a moment
so what is the self the self restraint
or self controlled person the person who
keeps it together the person who follows
through the person who can make
commitments and see them through so he
you notice little sense that the self
restraint or the self controlled person
has right principle they have the arkyd
they have a starting point and what that
means specifically is that they are not
only reasoning the right way they
actually have the right and the right
things that they're prioritizing this
might be quite complex in some
situations you know
Aristotle tends to look at simple
examples but a lot of the time the
things that we're faced with we have to
we have to juggle multiple priorities
and decide which of the different goods
that are not all compatible we're going
to select the so the person who is
self-restraint picks the right thing so
for example fairly easy choice do they
after making a promise to somebody
actually fulfill that promise even
though it would be very convenient to
not follow through on the promise
perhaps even pleasurable perhaps by
doing so they're managing to avoid
spending money all sorts of things that
we could talk about right that's a very
typical example of somebody who is
exercising self-control and if they do
that typically if that's their habitual
state they are any person who is
self-control their self restraint so
they have the right principle but they
also feel a desire and the desire that
they feel this is where they differ from
the virtuous the desire that they feel
is not aligned perfectly not harmonizing
with the right principle so they know
what the right thing to do is and they
don't really want to do it but they also
do want to do it because they make it
short so I put here they
choose to follow right principle they
could go either way
he's saying that there is human freedom
and part of that human freedom is the
freedom to say yeah I'm not going to do
what I know is right or what I feel is
right I'm actually just going to pursue
what's easy or what feels good or what
would be convenient we could come up
with all sorts of examples along those
those lines right what would give you
the goods that I want right now the
person who has self-control makes a
choice to follow principle and here's
what differentiates them from a person
who lacks self-control the person who
lacks self-control may also make a
choice they may have made pearl high
racist we have a video specifically on
that if you're interested in what choice
and Pride racist means for Aristotle the
person who lacks self-control may in
fact make a choice but then they don't
make the additional choice to actually
follow through not their initial choice
so their initial choice isn't really an
effective choice right it doesn't get
them there to where they need to be and
you know when we think about this in
very concrete terms there may be a lot
of steps involved in a process and in
order to exercise self-control you may
need to make a choice at each point or
you may simply need to make a choice
once and then just you follow throughout
it may need to remind yourself of it
there may be critical juncture points
where you say yeah I know I did decide
to make this investment in going this
way but now the temptation is getting in
it's stronger
so there's a lot of different
possibilities here and you know making
that choice might be a matter of having
other people there to support humans
that encourage you you did the right
thing now stick with it buddy
or you know reminding yourself you know
with with having one with the
philosophers called da Matta a little
sayings that you do to repeat to
yourself all of these things are
possibilities for cultivating
self-control but if certain points
somebody actually has to choose to
follow through and follow their
principle follow
what reason is telling them against what
their desires where passions are telling
them now he talks about the self
restraint person sticking with it this
is the way I'm translating that many
literally to remain in place right the
self the self restraint or self
controlled person sticks with what their
intention was more than the majority of
humankind so this could in fact be in
some degrees culturally relative you
know we know much more about the extent
of humankind and the variety of human
compartments and behaviors Aristotle's
thinking primarily of the Greeks of his
own time who were not particularly more
salt restrained I think than the rest of
us as mathematical Romans tend to think
pretty lowly that compares them to Roman
self-restraint that some of these things
vary according to the time so this
person is not yet at virtue which is
actually you know the best state that
you can be at besides superhuman virtue
which is probably not Hannibal for most
of us but it's a good state because
they're further along the line towards
virtue they stick with it more than most
other people do there may be some things
that they don't stick with that doesn't
mean that they're not self-restraint one
of the issues that Aristotle raises
which is a very important issue and what
we're going to talk about a little bit
more in another video specifically on
stubbornness or obstinacy it is what if
the person is mistaken about what the
true principle and the right choice are
what if the person sticks with something
that doesn't turn out to be the right
thing there's there's many cases in
moral life where we're mistaken about
you know the real priorities of goods
and how they should be weighed against
each other we do factual issues wrong
and then you have to revise later on you
know here would be a primary example you
know in the past you know relations
between men
women and particularly fathers and
daughters in many culture were quite
flop site and many people including
Aristotle's a certain extent would take
that as being just the norm and they
would draw you know what right principle
was from certain assumptions that we
don't we no longer share I think for a
good reason so you know for example the
female child might be treated in very
very different ways than a male child
which might not give her the chance to
develop in certain you know qualities or
certain aptitudes that the male child
would like for example going to school I
instead there would be steering them
towards something else like getting
ready for marriage and the idea was well
this is what is really good for them and
this is what is really good for the
others the boys so you know since that's
what we ought to do I'm going to stick
with that when my daughter says I want
to go to school like Little Billy Ennis
and not just get ready for marriage if I
may have one of these very very
traditional fathers very traditional in
our time now I might be sticking to
something that now we know we know
better about somebody's probably gonna
get upset and you know make a comment
about that let's just assume that that's
what a right principal is in this case
or right choice in that the person is
mistaken event so Aristotle says in
cases like that the person is in fact
being self controlled but in an
accidental way he says that here we go
the answer is accidentally it may be any
principle or choice essentially it's the
true principle and the right choice that
we want that the one that the person
stands by and the other one does not in
the sense that if the man chooses or
pursues something as a means to
something else that's something else is
essentially and the other thing is on
the
this object and his choice and by
essentially says we mean absolutely
so he says hence in a sense it is any
sort of opinion speaking absolutely it
is the true opinion that one stands by
and the other bei eminence so even
though we might be mistaken about what
it is that we're sticking with it's
better if we're sticking with what is in
fact true principle or right decision
but there is something still
praiseworthy about sticking with
something that turns out to be wrong not
so much if one actually finds out that
it is wrong however so just didn't one's
heels in is not that but we'll talk
about that in another video so this is a
very important moral state this is
probably what many people who we think
of as good people actually fit the bill
for when we apply Aristotle's ethics
many people are not yet virtuous or
perhaps never will be virtuous but they
can at the same time still be
self-restraint
or self-control